Speaker 1: I've told you before that there are
sort of like politician lies, things like, oh,
reducing taxes on the rich stimulates the job
creators to get out there and build businesses
or something like that. It's completely untrue.
But it's the type of thing that you actually have
to really do some research in order to sort
out and debunk and and counterpoint. And then
there's the types of lies that we've seen over
the last six years from the Trumpian wing of
the Republican Party, stuff like, I don't know,
Donald Trump is six foot three inches tall and
weighs £239. That's an obvious lie. And speaking
of that type of lie, Donald Trump's former doctor,
now Republican Congressman Randy Jackson, went on
the Greg Kelly Reports show on Newsmax and claimed
that Donald Trump is fitter than 90% of people his
age now. It's okay he's qualifying it by saying
people his age. But I can assure you that that's
not true. And I've got the numbers to back it up
in a moment. So let's listen to what Ronny
Jackson had to say here. And this is the type
of lie we're like, why even bother? Why bother
with something so obviously untrue? Obama and.
Speaker 3: Trump, now you're famous
for extolling the health virtues of
Donald Trump. You did so publicly, and a lot of
people were like, Oh, man, you're overdoing it.
But actually, let's face it, he is a very unique
specimen. I mean, anybody can see that he is 76
years old. He has the energy of a he's unique.
Speaker 1: That's true of.
Speaker 3: A 16.
Speaker 1: Year old.
I don't think you are a do me favorite.
Trump has the energy of a 16 year old.
Yet when all the other world leaders
walked around in Sicily, Trump was driven
on a golf cart. Real 16 year old energy.
Speaker 3: Tell us about his health, if you
don't mind. No, he's in great health. And people
will wonder, like, why is he so healthy? Because,
you know, he's famously doesn't have a really
great diet and he he doesn't exercise much.
You know, I've been playing golf and whatnot, but
you got to look at the, you know, his whole life.
I mean, during it throughout his life, he never
drank. He never smoked. He led a pretty healthy
life overall compared to a lot of folks. And so
I think that he's reaping the rewards of of a
healthy life early on. And he was in great
shape. I mean, I put him on the treadmill,
did a cardiac stress test on him. He knocked and.
Speaker 1: Now was the treadmill on because
just putting someone on a treadmill that's
off won't really stress the body too much.
Speaker 3: Out of the water. I
mean, he he was in the top 10%
of of everyone of his age. I mean, he he did
extremely well in his cardiac stress test. And
he he just you know, he's in great, great health,
to be honest with you. And, you know, and I didn't
overdo it, Greg. I'll say I'll point out that, you
know, I was very thorough in briefing his physical
exam, something we have not seen from the doctor
at the White House right now with regards to yeah.
Speaker 1: With Joe Biden, anything could be
going on. So this is not fat shaming. This is
life shaming. This is like him. You don't have to
lie about everything. You can say you like Trump's
policy and you can say you think Trump was good
for the country and you like the way Trump dealt
with Putin or whatever, but not like that. Trump
is one of the healthiest people his age around.
Remember, stress tests. Cardiac stress tests.
Okay. There's an analysis that was done,
a longitudinal analysis of cardiac stress tests.
The median exercise time for men. Trump's age
was 7 minutes and 22 seconds for a maximum
effort stress test. Does anyone in my audience
believe that Donald Trump could do maximum cardiac
stress for 7 minutes and 22 seconds? And remember,
that's the median. And we're supposed to believe
Trump isn't median, but that he's in the top
10%. There are four stages to the cardiac stress
test in among people, among men, Trump's age,
only 1% get to part four. So forget about
part four. But 15% of men complete part three.
They're telling us Trump isn't just in the
top 15% who would complete the third part?
Trump's in the top 10%, meaning of the
15% that get to complete part three.
Trump isn't even at the bottom of that group.
Gimme a break, guys. It's becoming North Korea
type stuff. Remember all the things they would
say about Kim Jong un and Kim Jong Il? And with
Kim Jong il, it was you know, he lifted a car
above his head. I think that was one of them.
I know that they said the first time he played
golf, he played 18 holes and got 18 holes in one
that double rainbows like follow the guy around
or whatever that Kim Jong Il doesn't defecate,
you know, all sorts of he created forms of energy
and it also felt yeah it's getting to be that that
to that degree and Greg Kelly you know his space
should be bright red maybe it is you can't tell
because of the makeup. But this is the type of
stuff that would make North Korean propaganda
news anchors sort of blush so absolutely
pathetic and, like, just lie about things
that are difficult to. Obviously realize are being
lied about. This one is tough, tough to believe.